Spare time, I'm actually in New York City just for the day, travelling, trying to see the city.
I just moved up here.
I love to just make travel plans.
Soccer. I'm really into sports.
Spare time, I watch a lot of movies, and I talk on the internet a lot, and I go shopping...
I am just writing.
Sing, dance...
I like hanging out with friends.
I go downtown, walk around, paint, eat.
I eat a lot.
It's my favorite thing to do.
I shop, I just lounge around, chill out, go to the pool, you know...
...nothing too exciting.
I like to fish. I like to hunt.
I just like to go out with friends and enjoy myself.
I like walking in the park around here, doing something laid-back.
In my spare time, I just play sports...
...hockey, biking, lacrosse.
I go see movies, I go see live shows, stuff like that.
In my spare time, I hang out with my friends, I go to the movies, I train.
I'm a martial arts teacher also.